federal health officials have made a  breakthrough in their investigation into  the lung illnesses and deaths linked to  vaping the Centers for Disease Control  and Prevention found vitamin E acetate  in all 29 samples of lung fluid taken  from patients it is the first time the  CDC is on a common suspect in patients  lungs damaged by vaping when heated and  inhaled vitamin E acetate is thought to  cause a chemical burn injury in the  lungs but the CDC says more tests still  need to be done we have to better  understand the pathology of how the  vitamin E that gets into the lungs and  causes the damage to the lungs occurred  vitamin C acetate is often used as a  thickener in black-market vaping fluid  containing THC the active ingredient in  marijuana but just 23 of the 29 tested  positive for THC at least 2,000  illnesses and 40 deaths have been linked  to vaping